well it's really good to see you guys
how have you been knowing that you seem
busy you seem joyful like you're working
on lots of stuff this is the best time
[Music]
yeah we're always the type of people
that try to find the silver linings and
look at it like the classes have flaws
so we're trying to find good in it
in a way it's kind of like harkening
back to how we knew you guys in the
beginning it's like DIY right this is
how we started this is what we really
love to do is like be in the studio
creating content people watch and we're
really starting to get back to those
roots and it's really amazing and walk
off the Earth's latest creation will be
enjoyed by millions of young Pokemon
fans around the world our kids are now
like aren't oldest giorgio is obsessed
he's always in that backyard throw his
pokeballs and stuff so when we told him
that we're gonna be writing the new
theme song he didn't really believe us
when they called us and asked us to try
out a demo we wrote a song that we
thought would be perfect for the Pokemon
series that sounded very Pokemon esque
and the action brought us back they're
like no we asked a lot here do this
because we wanted to sound like a walk
off the air song so we're like okay
that's easy I was also watching your eat
some beef series which is super fun yeah
our youngest Romeo is obsessed with food
and we're kind of a foodie family we are
always trying to cook through things and
try things we've never tried and try and
collect ik dishes from around the world
so we started doing that and just making
short stories about it and it seemed
there really resonate with our fans
we've designed eat some beats t-shirt
that we're selling in 100% of the
proceeds is going to red cross Canada so
yeah we're just we thought it was
another way to be able to raise some
money for that's amazing